[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings the past
year has seen some dramatic swings in
america's fight against covet after
sharp increases in new cases last winter
and over the summer the daily total has
dropped to less than 70 thousand again
but while the numbers are trending in
the right direction one organ man who
spent nearly a year in the hospital
shows it can sometimes be very hard to
recover from the disease our lead
national correspondent david begno has
his story david good morning what a
story good morning it's a raw story alex
castro got infected with covid before
there was a vaccine his wife told us
they didn't really take the virus
seriously they thought it was the
regular old flu
alex had one of the worst cases we have
ever heard of and he is now facing a
long slow
and uncertain road ahead
alex castro used to be able to swim cook
and hike
but now it takes every breath he has and
baby steps to just walk across his
living room he's just 44 years old and a
shell of the man he used to be
covid caused him heart failure and
ravaged his kidneys and his lungs
he spent 299 days at providence portland
medical center in oregon
108 of those days were spent on ecmo
which is a heart and lung bypass machine
i didn't know you could be on ecmo and
be awake yeah and walk
that's unbelievable would they walk him
like this every day it'd be like maybe
two three days three days a week alex's
oldest son aj showed us family videos of
alex walking in the hospital as blood
was being pumped out of his body and
then back into it doing the work of his
heart and lungs
as he walked the health care workers and
the nurses and the doctors all in the
icu were
their god center they literally saved my
dad's life alex had the heart of a lion
levi cole was one of the icu nurses who
cared for alex he fought like an animal
and he made it out of here against every
possible possible odd how does it make
you feel to hear that
happy
really happy we told alex what else levi
said the day they took him off of ecmo i
crawled in bed with him i gave him a big
hug
alex can't remember half of the time he
was in the hospital but boy did he
remember that
oh
levi said
i gave him a big hug and we were both
laughing
i had tears in my eyes with pure joy we
all dragged him across the finish line
but he did it himself
his reaction was the sweetest moment
in the eight hours that we spent with
alex his four children and his wife
amanda at their home in sandy oregon
we traveled there to see what life is
like for him now i just turned up his
the amount of oxygen that he's getting
through his nose
twenty-year-old aj is his dad's primary
caretaker during the day
alex is on oxygen around the clock and
his doctor told us he will be on it for
the rest of his life
even the smallest things take a lot out
of them don't they oh yeah like what
even like
going to the bathroom like walking with
a walker with me
to the bathroom he'll do pretty good and
then
it'll just like literally just hit him
out of nowhere and it's just like he's
super tired and he's out of breath and
we'll take a seat wherever he is just to
catch his breath again
one walk to the bathroom and about 10
simple exercises during occupational
therapy
really tired him out so he took a nap
pretty soon thereafter
it was physical therapy time
while you're standing here can you try
some knee bends
breathe breathe breathe your oxygen
level looks great
everyone's constantly watching his
oxygen saturation level which dropped to
73 when alex did some pretty simple knee
bends
95 to 100 is considered normal are you
okay with heading over to the couch yeah
okay his spirit seemed so strong he said
yes to everything they asked him to do
like walk across the living room baby
steps
and every breath he had
just standing on his feet
is actually probably a better exercise
than walking for him
think about that just standing regularly
is a goal for alex
the man who worked three jobs to support
his family
is now dependent on all of them
his wife and his oldest daughter marty
are now the breadwinners marty manages
the local burger king that alex used to
manage
he loved to work and he wants to do it
again
but it is unclear if he will ever be
able to
he's been out of the hospital 20 days
now there are notable improvements daily
and he is vaccinated by the way he got
the shot in the hospital
his doctor told us he is likely going to
need to get a lung transplant you might
be wondering what's the hospital bill i
mean 299 days in the hospital how
expensive is that well the hospital did
not want to tell us what the bill is but
they did say this whatever alex's
insurance doesn't pay
they'll cover the rest
thank god
yeah drew is here saying thank god david
we were talking about that during the
piece how is the family going to pay
these bills good to hear that they're
not going to have to although you do
have questions how are they doing
financially if he used to have a job at
the burger king now does not have any
going to be on oxygen the rest of his
life unclear when if he'll work again
look everybody's pitching in i mean you
got the daughter running the burger king
you got the son who's looking for a job
but is right now not working very hard
to find the job because his dad needs
some help the other kids are going to
school
everybody's pension pennies but they're
so thankful that he's home yeah i'm glad
i'm glad as well david thank you very
much you bet